Hello, and welcome to speaking of psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills, and I'm speaking to you from APA's Technology, Mind, and Society Conference in Washington. This is an interdisciplinary meeting aimed at assessing current efforts to understand and shape the interactions of human beings and technology, for identifying priorities for future work, and for promoting the exchange of ideas and collaboration among participants. Dr. Roberta Golancoff holds the Unidl-H. Rodney Sharp Chair in the School of Education at the University of Delaware and is also a member of the departments of psychology and linguistics. She directs the child's play learning and development lab whose goal it is to understand how children learn
您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是一档由美国心理学会制作的播客。我是主持人金·米尔斯，我正在华盛顿参加美国心理学会举办的“技术、思维与社会”会议。这是一场跨学科会议，旨在评估目前理解和塑造人类与技术互动关系的努力，确定未来工作的重点，并促进与会者之间的思想交流与合作。罗伯塔·戈兰科夫博士在特拉华大学教育学院担任Unidl-H. Rodney Sharp讲座教授，同时也是心理学系和语言学系的成员。她负责指导儿童游戏学习与发展实验室，其目标是了解儿童如何学习
language. She also conducts research on the benefits of play. Dr. Golancoff has written dozens of journal articles, chapters, and academic books, and presents at conferences all over the world. She has also written books for a mainstream audience, such as Becoming Brilliant, which is published by the American Psychological Association, reimagines what successful learning looks like in a dynamic, global world. Thank you for joining us today. My pleasure. I want to talk about touch screens because they've become really ubiquitous, and I think
语言。她还从事关于游戏益处的研究。戈兰科夫博士撰写了数十篇期刊文章、章节和学术书籍，并在世界各地的会议上发表演讲。她还为大众读者撰写过书籍，例如由美国心理学会出版的《变得卓越》（Becoming Brilliant），该书重新构想了在一个充满活力、全球化的世界中，成功的学习是什么样子的。感谢您今天加入我们。这是我的荣幸。我想谈谈触摸屏，因为它们已经变得非常普遍，而且我认为
every place you turn now, people either have a phone in their hands or a tablet. And more and more we're seeing people handing these devices to children at very young ages. Is giving a little child a touchscreen a good thing, a bad thing, neutral? What's your view on this? So, you know, we're not going to put the genie back in the bottle. So having a conference that APA just put on is a wonderful thing because it gives people the opportunity to talk about the effects of screens on kids. I hasten to say, even before I answer, that when kids were reading a lot in the past, people were
现在无论你走到哪里，人们手里要么拿着手机，要么拿着平板电脑。我们越来越多地看到人们在孩子很小的时候就把这些设备交给他们。给小孩子一个触摸屏是好事、坏事，还是中性的？你对此有什么看法？嗯，你知道，我们无法让时光倒流。所以美国心理学会举办这次会议是一件很棒的事情，因为它让人们有机会讨论屏幕对孩子的影响。在回答之前，我必须说，过去当孩子们大量阅读时，人们也
worried about their eyes. When television came along, people thought civilization was over, that kids would be glued to screens. So it seems like every time a new technology comes along, people blow whistles. And I'm not sure that the whistles that they're blowing are always justified. So even my 15, 16-month-old grandchild can't get enough of his father's phone when they call me on FaceTime. There's something so appealing about having buttons you can press, right? In the past, it was turning on the light switch, right? Now it's buttons on the phone, right? They're calling Alaska. We don't even know. And I think something like this needs to be harnessed, and that's a lot of the papers that I'm hearing here today. How can we use this
担心他们的视力。当电视出现时，人们认为文明要终结了，孩子们会整天盯着屏幕。所以似乎每当一项新技术出现时，人们就会发出警告。我不确定他们发出的警告是否总是合理的。所以即使是我15、16个月大的孙子，当他们用FaceTime给我打电话时，他也对父亲的手机爱不释手。有按钮可以按，这非常有吸引力，对吧？过去是打开电灯开关，对吧？现在是手机上的按钮，对吧？他们甚至不知道自己在给阿拉斯加打电话。我认为像这样的东西需要被利用起来，这也是我今天在这里听到的许多论文的主题。我们如何利用这种
fabulous drive that kids have to engage with technology to help them learn? And many of the research papers that are out and coming out are showing us that we can instantiate learning principles using technology. We can make it minds on and not just swiping, but we have to think to get an answer. We can make it engaging and not distracting when we don't break up a story with a sound effect. We can make it socially interactive, which we know is important for how kids learn. So we can instantiate the learning principles that we know work for kids learning using technology. So I know these devices are still relatively new, but how much do we know about the impact of them on child development. So, you know, the thing that's so amazing is that the iPad
孩子们参与技术的巨大动力来帮助他们学习？许多已经发表和即将发表的研究论文向我们展示了，我们可以利用技术来实现学习原则。我们可以让它变得“动脑”而不仅仅是滑动，我们必须思考才能得到答案。我们可以让它引人入胜而不是分散注意力，当我们不通过音效来打断故事时。我们可以让它具有社交互动性，我们知道这对孩子的学习很重要。因此，我们可以利用技术来实现我们所知的对孩子学习有效的学习原则。我知道这些设备还相对较新，但我们对它们对儿童发展的影响了解多少呢？所以，你知道，最令人惊奇的是iPad
is eight years old. It came out in 2010. Yeah. Imagine how rapidly this has spread. The iPhone itself was 2007. It's crazy. It's everywhere. It feels like we've had them forever. Yeah, and how could I live without it, right? Yeah. So in general, kids learn about the world through acting on it and through interacting with adults, caring, nurturing adults, and of course, other kids. So I don't want to short-circuit that. And I don't want kids to be on devices 24-7. That said, we have to use the research to guide us. So, for example, with Rebecca Doer, one of my postdocs at the University of Delaware,
已经八岁了。它是在2010年推出的。是的。想象一下它传播得有多快。iPhone本身是2007年推出的。这太疯狂了。它无处不在。感觉我们好像一直都有它们。是的，如果没有它我该怎么生活，对吧？是的。所以总的来说，孩子们通过作用于世界以及与成年人、关爱和养育他们的成年人，当然还有其他孩子互动来了解世界。所以我不想绕过这一点。我也不希望孩子们24小时全天候使用设备。话虽如此，我们必须利用研究来指导我们。例如，与我在特拉华大学的博士后之一丽贝卡·多尔（Rebecca Doer）合作，
we've shown that if a parent reads an electronic story from a tablet, with a kid versus if the kid reads the electronic story himself, the kid will get something out of the electronic story if they read it alone. But if they read the story with a parent, they get more from it. And that's because the parent can observe where the child is looking and talk about what the kid is interested in. The parent can find a child. The parent can find, the little pointing finger. And the tablet doesn't know anything about the child's life, but the parent can link up the story to the child's life.
我们已经证明，如果家长和孩子一起阅读平板电脑上的电子故事，与孩子自己阅读相比，如果孩子独自阅读，他们会从电子故事中获得一些东西。但如果他们和家长一起阅读，他们会从中获得更多。这是因为家长可以观察孩子在看哪里，并谈论孩子感兴趣的内容。家长可以找到孩子。家长可以找到那个小小的指尖。平板电脑对孩子的生活一无所知，但家长可以将故事与孩子的生活联系起来。
Oh, that dog, it's just like Nana has, right? So no wonder kids learn more from interacting with adults around technology. How is that different from just a paper or picture book? Well, that's a really good question. There is no question in the literature. It's pervasive. it's everywhere, that children learn a tremendous amount from reading with parents. They learn the grammar of the language. They hear academic language or expressions that they would never
哦，那只狗，就像奶奶家养的那只一样，对吧？所以难怪孩子们从围绕技术的成人互动中学到更多。这与纸质书或图画书有什么不同？嗯，这是一个非常好的问题。文献中毫无疑问。它是普遍存在的，它无处不在，孩子们通过与父母一起阅读学到了很多东西。他们学习语言的语法。他们听到学术语言或表达方式，这些是他们永远不会
hear in typical conversation. For example, I heard a three-year-old go, puff, and then he disappeared. Who talks like that? That's from a child's book, right? So some of those same things can happen in electronic books where children are exposed to new language, new voice, vocabulary, new sentence structures, just as they are when they cuddle up with parents with a traditional book. What worries me as a researcher is I want parents to spend time with their children. And I have this nightmare that someone will hand a tablet. It's probably happening today. Good night, Johnny, go read yourself a story. Oh, my God. So the child doesn't get the benefit of the physical cuddling with the parent, doesn't get the benefit of the parent's language and explanations,
在典型对话中听到的。例如，我听到一个三岁的孩子说，“砰”，然后他就消失了。谁会那样说话？那是儿童书里的内容，对吧？所以同样的一些事情也可能发生在电子书中，孩子们接触到新的语言、新的声音、词汇、新的句子结构，就像他们和父母依偎在一起读传统书籍时一样。作为一名研究人员，我担心的是我希望父母能花时间陪伴他们的孩子。我有一个噩梦，有人会递给孩子一个平板电脑。这可能今天就在发生。晚安，强尼，自己去读个故事吧。哦，天哪。所以孩子没有得到与父母身体亲密接触的好处，没有得到父母语言和解释的好处，
and doesn't get the benefit of asking for information. So we're doing a study in my lab now with Rebecca Dorr and my graduate student, Danielle Avalar, where we're going to look at the affect, the facial expression, and some physiological measures through the use of a bracelet, to look at what happens during storybook reading, because my hypothesis is it reduces parents' stress and makes parents happy, although sometimes they fall asleep, I can tell you, and it makes children happy to be able to engage with parents in this very close one-on-one way. So it sounds like what you're saying is don't use these devices as babysitters. This is not just hand the kid the phone so he'll stop crying. Well, it depends where you are.
也没有得到询问信息的好处。所以我们实验室现在正在和丽贝卡·多尔以及我的研究生丹妮尔·阿瓦拉（Danielle Avalar）进行一项研究，我们将观察情感、面部表情，并通过手环观察一些生理指标，来看看故事书阅读过程中发生了什么，因为我的假设是它能减轻父母的压力并让父母感到快乐，尽管有时他们会睡着，我可以告诉你，它也让孩子们能够以这种非常亲密的一对一方式与父母互动而感到快乐。所以听起来你的意思是不要把这些设备当作保姆。这不仅仅是把手机递给孩子让他停止哭泣。嗯，这取决于你在哪里。
what I would have given for a phone to hand my kid at a fancy restaurant, right? I mean, realistically, these things can be very useful. And it doesn't mean that you have to use them all the time. You can use them selectively. And it also depends on what's being portrayed, either on the telephone or on the tablet. Because this stuff is so new. And because we didn't have arguments, about how to instantiate the principles of learning on these things,
如果能有一个手机递给我在高档餐厅里的孩子，我愿意付出什么代价，对吧？我的意思是，现实地讲，这些东西非常有用。这并不意味着你必须一直使用它们。你可以有选择地使用它们。这也取决于电话或平板电脑上播放的内容。因为这些东西太新了。而且因为我们没有关于如何在这些东西上实现学习原则的争论，
it's now the right time, and people are creating more and more in the way of apps and software that shows kids things that's good for kids, that they can learn from. Sesame Street has something called Martha Speaks. It's a dog, and it teaches kids vocabulary, and they find that kids do, in fact, learn vocabulary. We have an app we created to teach three years. spatial skills to move things around to assemble puzzles on a screen. I can't tell you that it works
现在是合适的时机，人们正在创造越来越多的应用程序和软件，向孩子们展示对他们有益的东西，他们可以从中学习。《芝麻街》有一个叫《玛莎说话》（Martha Speaks）的节目。它是一只狗，它教孩子们词汇，他们发现孩子们确实学到了词汇。我们创建了一个应用程序来教三岁孩子空间技能，让他们在屏幕上移动东西来拼装拼图。我不能告诉你它是否有效
yet because we don't have all the data in. But I can tell you that kids love this. We do it in the context of a birthday party game and they keep visiting different individuals to prepare in different ways for the birthday party. So it can be very powerful for children's learning. is there an age that's too early to hand a child a touchscreen, do you think? I think in our society it's happening earlier and earlier, and I can't imagine having prohibitions against it. Now, you know, the American Academy of Pediatrics came out a few years ago with a stipulation that no child under two should get near a screen.
因为我们还没有拿到所有数据。但我可以告诉你，孩子们喜欢这个。我们在生日派对游戏的情境下进行，他们不断拜访不同的人，以不同的方式为生日派对做准备。所以这对孩子的学习非常有力量。你认为给孩子触摸屏有太早的年龄吗？我认为在我们的社会中，这种情况发生得越来越早，我无法想象会有禁止它的规定。现在，你知道，美国儿科学会几年前出台了一项规定，两岁以下的儿童不应靠近屏幕。
Guess what? They recently admitted they did that on no data. No data. Shame on them. And they have since adjusted that recommendation and weakened it. They also recognize that kids spend a lot of time on Skype and FaceTime with remote grandparents and uncles and And we know from research that I've done with my long-standing collaborator, Kathy Hirsch-Pasic, that kids can learn from conversations like Skype and FaceTime.
你猜怎么着？他们最近承认他们这样做没有任何数据支持。没有数据。真为他们感到羞耻。他们此后调整了该建议并放宽了要求。他们也认识到孩子们花很多时间在Skype和FaceTime上与远方的祖父母和叔叔阿姨交流。我们从我和我的长期合作者凯西·赫什-帕西克（Kathy Hirsch-Pasic）所做的研究中得知，孩子们可以从Skype和FaceTime这样的对话中学习。
It's different than watching television. Television isn't responsive. It doesn't respond to the child. But if I call you by name, Kim, what's this? And I show you an action with the doll. I can teach you that action just as well over Skype as I can in person. So are there guidelines for parents or some kind of like a good housekeeping seal? It's a great point.
这与看电视不同。电视没有响应性。它不会对孩子做出反应。但如果我叫你的名字，金，这是什么？我给你展示一个玩偶的动作。我可以像面对面一样，通过Skype很好地教你那个动作。那么有什么给家长的指导方针或某种类似“良好管家印章”的东西吗？这是一个很好的观点。
So there's an organization called Common Sense Media. And they really put out interesting information for parents about what are the movies that are good for kids. But they're mostly in the space that's above zero to three. And I think they're going to move down into the zero to three space. Because as I said, you know, more and more kids are being handed a phone to play with while their parent is involved. My kids only fought when I was on the phone, right? So if I had had something to hand them, I would have been pretty happy. So these guidelines and recommendations, are they based on scientific evidence?
有一个叫“常识媒体”（Common Sense Media）的组织。他们确实为家长提供了关于哪些电影适合孩子看的有趣信息。但他们主要是在0到3岁以上的领域。我认为他们会向下延伸到0到3岁的空间。因为正如我所说，你知道，越来越多的孩子在父母忙碌时被递给手机玩。我的孩子只有在我打电话时才会打架，对吧？所以如果我有什么东西可以递给他们，我会很高兴的。那么这些指导方针和建议是基于科学证据的吗？
Are they looking at the psychology? So I think the Common Sense Media Group has psychologists on their staff, and they do make recommendations based on people's knowledge. And the zero to three space, we still have to get there. I'm not aware of people who are making recommendations for that space. Now, in general, I don't want really little kids spending a lot of time on media anyway, but there are some shows that, that are quite charming and non-violent.
他们是在研究心理学吗？所以我认为“常识媒体”小组的员工中有心理学家，他们确实根据人们的知识提出建议。在0到3岁的空间，我们仍然需要努力。我不知道有人在为那个空间提出建议。现在，总的来说，我也不希望很小的孩子花太多时间在媒体上，但确实有一些节目非常迷人且没有暴力。
For example, I'm gonna give plugs here. There's octanauts, which my grandchildren in Oakland, California, love, and Puffin Rock, which my grandchild in New York loves. I only have seven grandchildren. It's perfect for a developmental psychologist. And these are charming little shows that the kids really love,
例如，我要在这里做个广告。有《海底小纵队》（Octonauts），我在加利福尼亚州奥克兰的孙子们很喜欢，还有《海鹦岛》（Puffin Rock），我在纽约的孙子很喜欢。我只有七个孙子。这对发展心理学家来说太完美了。这些都是孩子们非常喜欢的迷人的小节目，
and they teach you about it. animals, they teach you bad kindness. You know, we don't have Mr. Rogers anymore, but we have things like this. Nothing will replace Mr. Rogers, of course. And Sesame, Sesame, Sesame's great. But things like Telitubbies, not so much? So, you know, Telitubbies was a little weird because they had characters who spoke in non-standard ways. I don't mean a British accent. I mean, who didn't enunciate the words. right many times but you know
它们教你关于动物的知识，教你善良。你知道，我们不再有罗杰斯先生了，但我们有这样的东西。当然，没有什么能取代罗杰斯先生。而且《芝麻街》很棒。但是像《天线宝宝》（Teletubbies）这样的节目，没那么好？所以，你知道，《天线宝宝》有点奇怪，因为他们的角色说话方式不标准。我不是指英国口音。我是指他们没有清晰地发音。很多时候，但你知道
the language that children hear around them and hear address to them swamps any weirdness that they might hear on a particular television show and I remember watching episodes of teletubbies it was never my first choice because of that
孩子们周围听到的以及别人对他们说的语言，会淹没他们在特定电视节目中可能听到的任何奇怪之处，我记得看过《天线宝宝》的剧集，因为这个原因，它从来不是我的首选
but it did have a nice fantasy element and they did take kids to see cows and go to farms and there are so many experiences that children don't necessarily have firsthand, that they can only get mediated through media programs. So the fear when I was a child, and I think you mentioned this earlier, when we were not supposed to watch TV because it was going to rot our brains.
但它确实有一个很好的幻想元素，他们确实带孩子们去看牛和去农场，有很多孩子们不一定有第一手经验的经历，他们只能通过媒体节目来获得。所以当我还是个孩子的时候，恐惧是——我想你之前提到过这一点——我们不被允许看电视，因为它会腐蚀我们的大脑。
What does the research say now? I mean, what do we know retrospectively? Did television have that kind of an impact on people where perhaps we're not as articulate or bright or motivated as we might have been. Or as critical thinking. Critical thinking. Given our current political situation. It is the case that there's a group called the Kaiser Foundation,
现在的研究怎么说？我的意思是，我们回顾过去了解到了什么？电视是否对人们产生了那种影响，导致我们可能不像我们本可以的那样善于表达、聪明或有动力。或者像批判性思维。批判性思维。考虑到我们目前的政治局势。确实有一个叫凯撒基金会（Kaiser Foundation）的组织，
and they do research on media and how it is consumed. And they have reported that children in the middle years, elementary school, watch approximately 40 hours of television. a week. This sickens me because think of the things that they're not doing. They're not running around outside. Granted, some children live in neighborhoods that are dangerous. I get that. But there are after-school programs, hopefully, where they can play outside. They're not interacting as much with peers. So, as you used the word passive before, that's what TV does. And I think for adults, as well as for kids who have anxiety, it calms them down.
他们对媒体及其消费方式进行了研究。他们报告说，处于中年级的孩子，即小学阶段，每周大约看40小时的电视。这让我感到恶心，因为想想他们没有做的事情。他们没有在外面跑来跑去。诚然，有些孩子住在危险的社区。我明白。但希望有课后项目，他们可以在外面玩。他们与同龄人的互动没有那么多。所以，正如你之前用的“被动”这个词，这就是电视的作用。我认为对于成年人以及有焦虑症的孩子来说，它能让他们平静下来。
But your average kid doesn't have anxiety problems, nor does your average adult. So I don't see the justification for consuming as much media as children do. And you know, in the past, kids might open up a book or start coloring or creating a city out of paper. I mean, I love kids being bored, you know, because then they come up with stuff. I think it's happening less. And what that means is it's encouraging less creativity and curiosity, I think, than we've had in the past. And also less executive function, the ability to control your impulses, to switch rapidly and to hold things in working memory.
但你的普通孩子没有焦虑问题，普通成年人也没有。所以我看不出像孩子们那样消费这么多媒体的理由。而且你知道，过去，孩子们可能会打开一本书，或者开始涂色，或者用纸创造一个城市。我的意思是，我喜欢孩子们感到无聊，你知道，因为那样他们就会想出东西来。我认为这种情况正在减少。这意味着我认为它比我们过去鼓励的创造力和好奇心更少。而且执行功能也更少，即控制冲动、快速切换和在工作记忆中保持事物的能力。
Because I think when you're passive and you're not trying to accomplish, your ordinary daily kinds of play tasks that you do and you're a kid, you're not challenging yourself enough. So I don't think it's a wonderful thing for children to be watching as much television. And of course, how can I not mention that we have an obesity epidemic? Of course, some of that too is from the advertising and the fact that inexpensive junk food is often what's available. and, for example, low-income communities, and is frankly cheaper.
因为我认为当你被动且没有试图完成你作为孩子时所做的普通日常游戏任务时，你对自己挑战得不够。所以我不认为孩子们看那么多电视是一件好事。当然，我怎么能不提我们有肥胖流行病呢？当然，其中一些也来自广告，以及廉价垃圾食品通常是可获得的事实，例如，低收入社区，而且坦率地说更便宜。
So that's part of the problem, too. But it's a serious problem that we have so many kids with hypertension and type 2 diabetes. And if they were running around, burning off the calories they were eating, rather than sitting, passively watching television and eating, that'd be good. Have you looked at all into what's on the horizon for smart TVs that could be more interactive? So I love the we. And just to explain, that's the technology where you can actually play physical games. Like you can bowl, you can bat at baseball and do all kinds of things and play tennis.
所以这也是问题的一部分。但我们有这么多孩子患有高血压和2型糖尿病是一个严重的问题。如果他们跑来跑去，消耗掉他们吃的卡路里，而不是坐着，被动地看电视和吃东西，那会很好。你有没有研究过智能电视在未来可能变得更具互动性的前景？所以我喜欢Wii。解释一下，那是你可以真正进行体育游戏的技术。比如你可以打保龄球，你可以打棒球，做各种各样的事情，还可以打网球。
You can work up a sweat playing with a lot. We, which I think is great, and I hope that we have more things like that coming down the pike for kids and adults. Yeah. Great. Well, thank you very much for joining us. My pleasure. Speaking of psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts
你可以通过玩Wii出一身汗，我认为这很棒，我希望我们未来能有更多这样的东西给孩子和成年人。是的。太棒了。好吧，非常感谢你加入我们。这是我的荣幸。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客
such as APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research, and progress notes, which discusses the practice of psychology. You can find all APA podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, www.spakingof Psychology.org, to listen to more episodes and see more resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
例如《美国心理学会期刊对话》（APA Journals Dialogue），讨论最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究；以及《进展笔记》（Progress Notes），讨论心理学实践。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到所有美国心理学会的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看关于我们讨论主题的更多资源。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯，这是《心理学谈话》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。